Does this work?
Hello?
Am I vertical?
Am I wide?
I probably could be wide.
I really wanted to be.
Wide doko.
Hello everybody!
Okaerinasai masen!
Gojijin-sama, ojo-sama!
Welcome to Kyoyuki.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, that's not spam, buddy.
Wide.
How do I be wide?
Hold on.
No, I'm long!
Wrong way!
I don't think I like being long.
I don't know.
That's not wide.
That was a big stretch.
Everybody, posture check.
Ready?
3, 2, 1!
Posture check!
Oh god, I can't stop getting long!
So long, so long.
Anyways, I'm here to sing.
Hold on.
I actually didn't really set up any of my stuff, so give me one second.
We'll put this here.
Oop.
And... yeah!
Okay, let's
get started.
Let's keep it up.
And... yeah!
Yaaay!
And...
here we go!
And... yeah!
I hope you guys are having a good evening.
Oh, thank you for the dono.
So, be sure to listen.
I don't truly plan on streaming on Mondays, but I don't know, usually when I'm in a sad mood, karaoke cheers me up.
And so, I thought I could just do a karaoke.
But this wasn't planned.
So true!
So yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Karaoke makes me feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good, feel good.
And I thought maybe now would be a time to try shorts.
Shorting.
I'm short-circuiting.
I'm uh...
What do I say?
Wait, what's the word?
What am I saying?
Oh, um...
Short songs only?
That would be kind of difficult.
What is a short song only?
Actually, I have no idea.
You're already short enough?
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
I'm thinking maybe going like an hour.
Oh, TV size!
Oh my gosh, yeah!
I'll add in my TV size.
Dango?
You know what?
Let's do it.
I haven't sung that song in a long time.
Wait.
Oh no!
Okay, so I basically use this program called...
JoySound on the Switch.
I have to buy...
I have to buy the 24 hours.
Because it said that I had 100 free.
But I can only pick from a certain amount.
Can you do anime OPs?
I can!
I can sing whatever I want!
Isn't that so awesome?
Oh my gosh, I clicked on it and it already said 99.
Okay, hold on.
If I...
I have the money, so...
I just have to purchase it.
Actually, I'm only going to purchase an hour.
I don't know if that's worth the amount.
But you know what?
Dango...
Do they not have it?
Okay, then never mind.
We're going to find it on YouTube.
This is already working out really well for us, you guys.
Minty Mondays!
No...
Mintara Mondays!
Daikazoku!
Karaoke.
Let me make sure this one sounds good.
Okay, it sounds good.
Okay, first song.
Thank you.
JoySound finds...
Oh, no.
Let me...
I don't...
It's okay.
I told you.
I already have the funds.
Is this archived, boss?
Yeah.
Oh.
Probably.
Let me know if the audio is too low.
Yanjana yaki dango
Yasashi andango Sukoshi yume migachi na tsukimi dango Osumashi koma dango Yotsugo kushi dango Minna minna awosete Hyaku ni kazoku
赤ちゃんだんごも 幸せの中で 年寄りだんごは 目を細めてる 仲良しだんご 手をつなぎ 大きな丸いわになるよ
This is what I get for thinking I I remember the lyrics.
It's the opposite of YASASHI.
It's KANASHI.
How's the audio, by the way?
Is it okay?
Thank you.
It's like, it's over!
Yay!
Yay, yay, yay!
Dango daikatoku from Clannad.
Oh my gosh, thank you for the Akadono!
Thank you!
Take my money.
Thank you for the lovely performance.
We love you.
Thank you so much, Deadly Nerd!
Thank you!
Oh my gosh.
It's way too much.
Thank you!
Ushio.
Why did you do that to us?
What do you mean?
Clannad Tascaru.
Actually, there's another Clannad.
Clannad sang that I really...
Oh.
Sorry.
Didn't mean for the double audio.
That I really love to sing.
Let me see if they have it.
It's the...
It's the opening from the second season.
Toki... Tokiyo... To... Ki...
Let me turn... Toky...
Tokiyo...
Kizamu...
Oh my gosh, my JoyCon key.
Let's see if they have it.
Oh!
I think that's it!
Is this it?
Wait.
No, no, the lyrics are wrong.
I can probably find it on YouTube though.
A karaoke of it.
Go away.
Maybe this is just YouTube karaoke today instead of Joy-san karaoke.
Luckily I haven't bought the subscription yet.
Tokioki...
Kizamu...
Uta...
Let me see if this sounds good.
Okay.
It sounds good enough.
It sounds like a karaoke so it doesn't sound like I won't get...
It sounds like a karaoke so it sounds like I won't get copyrighted.
Uh...
Key karaoke night.
Oh my gosh!
Key songs are kind of tricky.
Um, because...
For some reason...
Uh, for some reason...
They're not really on like...
JoySound and stuff.
Maybe in actual Japan, but for like these...
For like the home one, it's...
Um, a lot of them aren't.
Maybe we will do key karaoke.
Kind of fits the background.
It fits the vibe, right?
Alright, this is...
Tokioki zamu uta from...
Clannad.
Also...
Kimi dake ga sugisatta saka no tochuu wa Atatakana hidamari ga ikutsu mo dekite ta Boku hitori ga koko de yasashii Atatakasa wo omoikaeshiteru Kimi dake wo Oh, I loved you, only you.
The wind makes my eyes blur, and it makes me feel far away.
I will always remember, even if everything changes, just one thing, just one thing.
It's commonplace, but I'll show it to you, the one that is full of brilliance, just one thing.
I will always, always protect it.
Oh, so out of breath.
I've been singing this song for so long.
Even though it's already spring, and the cold days continue, I woke up earlier than the alarm clock.
You, who makes three servings of breakfast, are standing there.
Only you.
Only you are not by my side.
Until yesterday, you were right by my side.
You were looking at me.
Bing bing!
Hongji, it's me!
It's me!
Only you.
I've been loving you.
I'm singing this song.
It's a song.
Our, our time.
It's time weourcing, our time we've cut damaged.
Even if only one of the Te슴 just keeps on fresh, I won't go.
Ok,
I gotta prepare myself.
Yeah, yeah, Tokio Kizamu Uta.
From Clannad.
Yep, yep.
Yippee!
Thank you guys, thank you!
I'm really good, thank you!
Thank you for the party, party!
Thank you for the clapping!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the donuts as well, you guys.
Thank you so much, thank you, thank you.
Loved it when you sang Odoriko from Bondi.
Maybe I will sing it again tonight, who knows.
Who knows, who knows.
Who knows, who knows, who knows.
Whatever.
I'll sing whatever I want.
Ningyo Hime from Chobits.
Oh my gosh.
I don't even remember how that goes.
I only remember the opening.
I think if I heard the ending, I would know it.
But if I...
Here, I'm gonna put on the BGM of...
Even if we're not using it.
JoySound BGM.
Live Shorts are a thing.
Yeah, isn't it crazy?
My Soul, Your Beats?
I wonder if they have that one on here.
Actually, you know what?
Let's just do YouTube.
Let's just YouTube it.
For some of these though, I'm gonna want to do it on JoySound just so I can change the key.
Depending on the song, you know?
My Soul, Your Beats.
Actually...
How does that song go again?
Do, do, do, do, do.
Do, do, do, do, do, do.
Are you just doing any song today?
No, I'm just singing whatever we want.
OJ Fruits Basket.
Oh my god, that's a good one too.
Okay, I can try and sing this one.
But I don't remember it entirely.
I think it'll come back to me if I hear it.
You know?
Maybe.
We'll see.
Okay.
Shut up JoySound.
This one should be good.
Let me test it.
Okay.
It sounds a little crunchy, but...
Kinda adds to the old school anime vibe.
This isn't even that old of an anime, but...
Woah, woah, woah.
The bass is going crazy.
Let's go.
Let's get it.
Ah, that's good.
Let's get that.
That's good.
That's a good one.
Next, let's go with the V.
We've got a complete collection of songs here.
The song is called Dying and it's about a girl who finds herself in a handshake.
Let's go with the girl who finds herself in a handshake.
Okay, I don't like this.
I don't like this instrumental at all.
Hold on.
I'm so sorry.
One more time.
Kind of wasn't so good.
You know what?
Let me check this one.
Oh, I'm afraid to use... I'm afraid to use official instrumentals.
I'm afraid that YouTube is going to be like, hey, hey, hey, no, no, no.
Oh, wait, let me see this one.
Okay, this one works much better.
Okay.
Sorry, guys.
Karaoke planet.
Ah, instrumental.
What is karaoke planet?
Is it like one of those YouTube channels that just has a bajillion
captions?
Kiss Kiss Falling Up.
My gosh, you know what I've been thinking of so much recently?
Is the is the ending for Ouran.
Oh my gosh, it's so good.
Na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
Na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na, ba-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
Ba-ba-ba-bam-bam-bam, ba-bam, bam, bam.
It's so good.
I think I.
No, no.
I don't know.
I think I prefer it over the opening.
There's just something about it that's so nostalgic-sounding about it.
It's so good.
Okay.
Yes, yes, shishou!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Okay.
Okay, let's try this again.
I keep turning it up, only to feel like I'm going to have to turn it down again.
眠い朝は 襟の帯を きつく締め
教室のドアくぐると ほんの少し 胸を張って 歩き出せる
そんな日常に 吹き抜ける風 家で寝て スタンプに 立って
A little pause... and we are back.
Was I supposed to start?
A
little pause... and we are back.
A little pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
Was I supposed to start?
This is certified karaoke.
That's how you know this is real.
This is the real deal.
That was funny.
That was silly.
That was my soul, your beats?
Here, here, here.
What's up?
You're singing it perfectly.
Thank you.
You're too kind.
Oh my gosh, thank you for the 50.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for your lovely singing.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, man.
Your singing is so beautiful.
Thank you.
We're too quiet.
Quine.
Oh, Final Fantasy.
Oh my gosh.
Oh my gosh, I wanted to sing Eyes on Me last time.
So I'm going to sing it.
I'm so excited.
I love this song so much.
I have a question.
Are you a Pikmi?
Am I a Pikmi?
What counts as a Pikmi?
No, I think I'm a...
I would hope that I'm a girl's girl.
I think I'm a...
I would like to think that I'm a girl's girl.
I'm like, yeah, you go, girl.
You go, girl.
That's what I think.
Also, welcome, new viewers.
I know that, like, with...
With being short, some...
I was going to say strange.
No, you're not strange.
Sorry, we get a new audience.
So it's a little different than usual, but I think it's kind of fun to...
I think it's fun to kind of get new people finding me as well, right?
I'm Mint.
I'm a Vtuber.
I'm a ghost.
Yeah.
I sing sometimes.
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
Spice and Wolf started... I think it has started airing, hasn't it?
I haven't watched it yet.
But I want to.
Because obviously Spice and Wolf...
It has?
Oh, today!
Oh my gosh.
Wow, wow.
Oh, wait, wait.
Two episodes are out already?
Oh my goodness.
Holo is a Vtuber.
I saw that.
Oh my gosh.
Holo live.
It's crazy.
Will this be archived?
I intend on it being archived, yes.
But it's all up to YouTube.
Hi, Mint.
Nice to meet ya.
Hi, Adam.
Nice to meet you too.
Thank you guys for all the donations.
I am reading them.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Eyes on me from...
Let me check if this one's okay.
But this is from Final Fantasy.
Okay.
It sounds good.
Okay, hold on.
Where does it start?
Okay, here we go.
I might have to turn it down though.
Let's see.
Whenever I sang my songs on the stage on my own I never said my words Wishing they would be heard I saw you smiling at me Was it real or just my fantasy You'd always be there in the corner of this This tiny little bar My last night here for you Same old songs,
just once more My last night here with you Maybe yes, maybe no I kind of liked it your way How you shyly placed your eyes on me Oh, did you ever know That I had mine
Darling, so there you are With that look on your face As if you're never hurt As if you're never down Shall I be the one for you Who pinches you softly But sure If frown is shown then I will know that You are no dreamer
So let me come to you Close as I want to be Close enough for me To feel your heart beating fast And stay there as I whisper, how I loved your peaceful eyes on me.
But did you ever know that I had mine on you?
Darling, so share with me Your love if you have enough Your tears if you're holding back Or pain if that's what it is How can I let you know More than the dress and the voice Just reach me out then you will know that you are not dreaming Darling so there you are With that look on your face As if you're never hurt As if you're never hurt As if you're never hurt
I saw someone in the chat say, Go, dead girl, go.
Something from Full Moon.
Oh my gosh.
It's one of my first ever videos I uploaded on YouTube.
It's gone forever now.
It's gone...
It's long, long gone forever.
But...
I once sang a cover of...
From this...
Oh, wait.
I think I just clicked it.
No, I don't want that one.
How does this one go again?
The early days...
It actually was the early days of YouTube.
I'll have to see how this one goes.
I don't remember.
Oh my god, my ears.
My ears.
It's been so long...
It's been so long since I've sang any of these before.
I can't...
I remember Eternal Snow maybe the best.
What's Myself?
I can't remember.
Oh, I know this one.
I remember, I remember, I remember.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'll do this one.
Myself from...
Full Moon.
of Sagashite Tell me I really care How much I feel I'm overflowing with tears Okay it's gonna take me a second to get back into it...
What I've
lost is too much to forget Nothing I'll ever mostly forget
A little pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
I don't think I'll remember the rest though.
Here, we'll do a short version of that one.
We'll just fade, fade, and fade out.
I can do Eternal Snow though.
I know this one better.
Let's test the audio.
Holy bass!
Thank you for watching this video, I hope you enjoyed it and I will see you in the next video.
That
was too early.
I love you.
I wish I could show you what the background I've been looking at on this video has been the whole time.
It's been like these horses...
It's been like horses and...
And like some of them look really goofy because they're cartoon...
Or not cartoon.
They're like statues of cartoon horses.
I don't understand why.
It was distracting me so much.
Snake Eater cover, when?
Oh my gosh.
Do you want me to sing Snake Eater?
Is that what you're saying?
I can't.
I'm not allowed.
No, I'm just kidding.
Okay, we can do Snake Eater.
Let's sing it, baby.
What a thrill With darkness and silence through the night What a thrill I'm searching and I'll melt into you What a fear in my heart But you're so supreme I give my life, not for honor, but for you, snake eater, in my time, there'll be no one else, it's the way I fly.
I'm still in a dream, snake eater, and some day you go through the rain, and some day you feed on a tree frog.
This ordeal, the trial to survive, for the day we see.
I give my life, not for honor, but for you, snake
eater, in my time, there'll be no one else,
it's the way I
fly.
I'm still in a dream, snake eater, in my time, there'll be no one else, it's the way I fly.
I'm
still in a dream, snake eater, snake eater.
I'm still in a dream,
snake eater, snake eater.
Like always , in my dream.
Tou.
To.
I'm so glad, I'm so glad, I'm so glad.
Thank you guys for all the donos, I really appreciate it.
Pretty good.
Secret base from Anohana.
Calling to the night.
I could try.
Sins of the father.
Oh my god, that song is so hard.
It's just so difficult.
I don't know what to say.
I've never tried singing it so much.
But...
When I say that, I mean like I tried singing it in my room.
But I had to...
I was being quiet because I didn't know if my neighbors would be able to hear me.
In Japan.
Let's see if the calling to the night...
I didn't intend on this just being Metal Gear.
But we can try.
A couple of Metal Gear songs.
Let's do this one.
Let me see if this one is good.
Let me try this one.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, instrumental.
Here we go.
Let me check it.
Okay.
Hopefully it's good.
Wait, let me get the lyrics.
Calling to the night.
Wait, lyrics.
I forgot to write.
This is from Metal Gear Solid Portable Ops.
Yes.
Let's see.
I might have to adjust the volume a little bit.
But that's okay.
What's that sound?
What's that sound like?
Through the night.
To the day.
When everything is gone.
Carry the soul.
Through the night.
All away from the dry lands.
In the sun we see.
Fighting over lines.
All our dreams and wishes.
We send hope for safe keeping.
Fighting for what's right.
I know there's one part I always get the timing off on.
So apologies in advance if I don't remember.
Calling to the night.
To dream.
Again in the light.
Waiting for a storm to rise.
A little pause... and we are back.
Hear the ringing echoes in the splitting horizon.
Calling to the night.
That one is so hard.
Difficult.
That was Calling to the Night from Metal Gear Solid.
Portable Apps.
It's a really tough song though.
It's hard for me to sing it even.
Let's see.
I hope people said Sins of the Father but...
I'm gonna sound not as good as Donna Burke.
At all.
Simple and Clean?
Okay we can do that one next.
We'll do that one.
Wait.
You mean Simple and Clean English.
Not... what is the Japanese one?
Hikari?
Right, right?
Wait.
Japanese... yeah which one are you...
Both!
Wait I see a lot of people saying Hikari.
Wait.
No.
I mean which one should I sing?
Simple and Clean or Hikari?
Either one is good.
Either.
Spanish version.
Oh.
I'm gonna run it through Google Translate and just...
Okay.
Simple and Clean preferred.
I will do Simple AND Clean.
But before that I will do Sins of the Father.
Oh gosh.
I'm really nervous about...
Don't.
Okay.
If you were thinking of clipping this, please don't.
Because I don't know if it'll be any good.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
I think it starts right away.
Wait.
Hold on.
When does it start?
In the deepest nights Reaching out, grasping for a fleeting memory All these thoughts keep piercing this broken mind I fall but I'm still standing Emotionless Emotionless
Far in the distance There is light A light that burns these scars of old All this pain reminds me of what I am I'll live I'll become alive I need to be here.
Words
that kill.
Would you speak them to me?
With your breath so still.
It makes me believe.
In the father's sins.
Let me suffer now.
And never die.
I'm alive.
Oh this song is so hard.
Oh my god.
But I would listen to it all the time in Japan.
Like walking to him from home.
Oh my god.
It was like my power anthem.
But I never got to practice it at karaoke so...
Pride.
Feeds their blackened hearts.
And the thirst must be quenched to fuel hypocrisy.
Cleansing flames is the only way to repay.
Repent.
Renounce.
What made you words that kill.
Would you speak them to me?
With your breath so still.
It makes me believe.
Oh god, oh god.
The sins.
Never die.
Can't wash this blood off our hands.
Let the world fear us all.
It's just means to an end.
Our salvation lies.
In love are the sins.
Let me suffer now.
In my heart are the light of the dark.
In his eyes...
Whoa...
Gluh replete rapid-re beaches.
Oh gosh I've never sung that at all.
Glow Midwest hard too fast.
Like I said, whenever I would practice in my room, it would be like, I would be like as quiet, like without, like trying to sing it but very quietly because I'm like, what if my neighbors can hear me?
What if like I'm outside, like someone's outside and you just hear me go, whoa, whoa, how?
Oh, you should keep practicing loud.
I'll try.
Now that I'm back home, I can, at my maid cafe, I can keep practicing louder, louder.
Sorry, sorry to all my neighbors.
I only care what my neighbors in Japan think, I guess.
Also, oh my gosh, S-L-I-D, bunch of numbers.
Thank you for the akadono.
Thank you for the song.
Thank you.
Thank you guys for all the donos.
Thank you so much.
Love the streams, especially the karaoke.
You rejuvenated my passion for drawing.
Oh my gosh.
Yippee, thank you.
Or rather, yes, thank you for the dono.
I'm so happy about you coming back to drawing.
Sorry, not sorry, neighbors.
Exactly.
My God has returned.
My, my, my God.
Thank you guys for the dono.
Who was thinking it actually, it sounded great.
Would, whoa ho again.
It's those, well, hose are really hard to, to, and like, I love how Donna Burke her voice like it's so raspy.
So I like try to kind of do that, but I'm not good at it.
But like, she has like such a powerful voice.
So I feel like mine completely pales in comparison, but that's okay.
It's all for fun, right?
I'm not a professional here.
This one is good for simple and clean.
No, no.
I need no words.
No Utada Hikaru backup.
Actually, I might have to do... let me do Hikari.
Let me type in Hikari, but I'll sing simple and clean.
Oh, this is perfect!
Wait, let me see.
I don't like the way it sounds, so hold on.
Oh no, you can hear the Hikari vocals, you know what I mean?
Oh wait, this is Gainashi.
Okay, good, good, good.
Because it's the same intro, right?
Let me check.
Let's listen to this one.
Please, oh baby, don't go Simple and clean is the way that you're making me feel Tonight, it's hard to let it go
You're giving me too many things lately You're all I need You smiled at me and said Don't get me wrong, I love you But does that mean I have to meet your father?
When we are older, you're not nice And no, I don't think life is quite that simple When you walk away, you don't hear me say Please, oh baby, don't go Simple and clean is the way that you're making me feel Tonight, it's hard to let it go So simple and clean,
oh The daily things like this and that What is what that keeps us all busy Are confusing me That's when you came to me and said Wish I could prove I love you But does that mean I have to walk on water?
When we are older, you'll understand It's enough when I say so And maybe some things are that simple When you walk away, you don't hear me say Please, oh baby, don't go Simple and clean is the way that you're making me feel Tonight, it's hard to let it go Hold me,
whatever lies Oh my god, my throat!
Each morning is a little later on Regardless of warnings The future doesn't scare me at all Nothing's like before When you walk away You don't hear me say Please, oh baby, don't go Simple and clean is the way that you're making me feel Tonight, it's hard to let it go Hold me,
whatever lies beyond this warning Is a little later on Regardless of warnings The future doesn't scare me at all Nothing's like before Hold me, whatever lies beyond this warning Is a little later on Regardless of warnings The future doesn't scare me at all Nothing's like before Nothing's like before Another day disturbing you Anything else you do Everything here...
Nothing's like you Nothing's like the warm Nothing's like me The rest was simple and clean.
Simple and clean.
Could have fooled me.
What do you mean can't hit high notes?
I said I can't hit them as well.
Oh my gosh, good playlist.
Thank you for the 70.
Oh my gosh.
Your voice is so powerful.
Thanks for spoiling us with your voice.
Your voice is peaceful, soothing, and beautiful.
Thank you!
Thank you so, so much.
Thank you guys for all the donuts.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
What could be next?
I can go for probably like another...
20 minutes or so.
So we can do a couple more...
songs.
Ikenai Borderline.
Okay, okay, okay.
Ikenai...
Space Odyssey.
Oh my gosh, you know that's not Space Odyssey.
I've been singing...
Actually...
Sorry, I'm going to sing something...
too.
That I want to sing also.
Thank you!
Thank you for treating to me...
that taste of my childhood.
It's mine too!
It's mine too.
Oh my gosh, that makes me want to bring up something.
Okay, sorry.
I have a super un-based taste.
Or un-based opinion.
Okay, so the other day...
I did karaoke.
And someone requested one of the Free Run songs.
And I didn't recognize it.
And someone in the comments was like...
She said she loves Free Run.
But she didn't even know...
the name of the song.
I'm sorry.
I don't like...
Well, okay, the OP is not as bad.
The ED, I really love the chorus...
of the ED.
But I cannot...
Oh my god, the song starts and I...
I'm sorry.
Oh no, one of those types of...
No, no, no!
I am not.
I am typically not one of those types of people.
I am almost always...
a true believer in listening...
to the opening and the ending every time.
But...
Not the best...
Millet?
Is that how you pronounce it?
Song?
Like, when she starts and she goes...
It's alright.
And then in the background it goes...
Yeah, I'm alright.
I'm okay.
Yeah, I'm okay.
I can't.
I just...
There's something about it that literally...
grates my spine.
The chorus, though, is so beautiful.
And I love it so much.
But just the beginning of the song makes me be like...
Okay, next episode.
I'm sorry.
Well, when you put it like that...
Honestly fair.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry that it is an un-based opinion.
But, you know, I'm so based all the time...
I have to have some un-based opinions.
Right?
I can't be perfect, you guys.
Jeez.
But this song...
This song is perfect.
Perfect.
Superb Xing Superb Sings Superb Xing Superb Sings She got the terribly longม She's having a whoa when she put the ?
Mommy's dead.
With Mom
A little
pause...
and we are back.
A little pause... and we are back.
One of my favorite things about this song is when they play it at, like, any Kura, like, any anime song events.
Um...
When the chorus comes, people will break UO's, which are really bright glow sticks, and just...
It's called...
It's called cycloning.
They just...
They just swirl them around a lot.
It's so fun!
Look, the eyes work with it, because of the song...matter.
Sneaky.
Not the giddy-giddy eyes.
Sure.
I'm serious!
I'm serious.
I'm dead serious.
I'm always dead serious.
I'm dead serious!
Um...
Let's see, what else?
What else?
Thank you for the dono.
Thank you!
It'd be interesting to sing...
Hear you sing Ace Combat songs one day.
Maybe one day.
My partner heard Yukaha-san run into Ikina borderline from the other room, and he said, I'm glad she's back on her bullshit.
I'm glad she's back on her bullshit.
What do you mean by that?
Also, Shrimp, thank you for the sex change.
Thank you for the fantastic voice.
You really helped me stay awake during work.
Oh, good luck with work!
I'm gonna try singing this song.
It's not a Japanese...
It's not an anime song, I'm sorry.
But maybe...
We can do whatever we want.
We don't have to do just anime songs.
I saw someone asking for Phantom of the Opera, but I honestly don't think my voice can handle it today.
But I honestly don't think my voice can handle it today.
We'll see, we'll see, we'll see.
Maybe I can.
Who knows.
This song, I'm gonna try and do it.
Usually I sing it...
Actually, maybe I shouldn't sing it.
I don't know.
Maybe I shouldn't sing this.
Maybe my voice isn't good for this either.
I don't know.
You know what?
Whatever.
I can sing whatever I want.
Do it, Min.
Ganba.
Okay.
Take a break and sing Tequila.
No, we only have...
I only plan on singing not very much longer anyway.
Just have fun.
Yeah, we're just having fun with it.
You can sing whatever you want.
But...
Yeah, I'll try it.
If it doesn't sound good, I'm really sorry.
But I love this song.
This is another song that I would listen to repeat all the time when I was in Japan.
I'm basically singing a couple of my comfort songs.
Well, Sins of the Father was a comfort song.
This is a comfort song.
What else did I listen to?
Sing!
The Carpenter song was a comfort song.
So...
Okay.
I'm going to try and sing this one.
This is Mariana Cross by Ghost.
But I can't tell if the key will be okay for me.
We'll see!
We were speeding together Down the dark avenues
But besides all the stardom All we got was blues But through all the sorrow We were riding high
And the truth of the matter is I never let you go Let you go I never let you go.
We were scanning the cities, walking to greater do's.
But besides all the glamour, all we got was bruised.
But through all the sorrow, we were riding high.
And the truth of the matter is, I never let you go.
Let you go.
You go down just like Holy Mary, Mariana, Mariana Cross.
Not just another Bloody Mary, Mariana, Mariana Cross.
If you choose to run away with me, I will tickle you internally.
And I see nothing wrong with that.
Marineris Ars.
We were searching for reasons to play by the rules.
But we quickly found out it was just for fools.
But through all the sorrow, we'll be riding high.
And the truth of the matter is, I'll never let you go.
Let you go.
Never gonna let you go, chat!
You go down just like Holy Mary, Mariana, Mariana Cross.
Mariana, Mariana Cross.
Not just another Bloody Mary, Mariana, Mariana.
You go down just like Holy Mary, Mariana, Mariana Cross.
Your beauty never ever scared me, Mariana, Mariana Cross.
If you choose to run away with me, I will tickle you internally.
And I see nothing wrong with that.
Nothing wrong with that.
I can't tell.
I know it's not.
Just a laugh.
I am not going to let you go, chat.
And I'll be the one to say this, You go down just like Holy Mary, And I will tickle you internally.
I'm not going to let you go, chat.
Mariana Cross.
Let me take the baby down.
And I'm the one to say this, You go down just like Holy Mary, Mariana Cross.
Okay, let me do it.
I can't do that.
I don't know if I could do it.
Okay.
You know what?
Phantom of the Opera.
Let's just see if my... Let's see.
Let's see.
What is... What is a Phantom of the Opera song?
Just the original.
Phantom of the Opera is here inside my mind.
That one?
Or another... Or any... Just a Phantom of the Opera song.
Short-ish.
Not really.
Think of me?
Okay.
All I ask of you?
The one you like the most?
The point of no return?
That song is dirty!
Let me see if this one's good.
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Let me see if the man speaks.
No, I don't want it to be a solo.
All I ask of you.
Karaoke.
Female part only.
Gosh, I love Youtube.
You sing Raul?
No, no, no, no.
Christine part...
Christine part only instrumental.
Christine... No, no, no.
Raul part... Oh, wait!
Oh, I'm sorry.
I should put in male part only.
I put in the wrong thing.
Okay, I don't know who this Clark on stage guy is, but I'm using your work.
Thank you very much.
It says sing along with me, so...
Hopefully he sounds good.
I believe in him.
He's got a lot of subscribers.
I'm still standing.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Go ahead, Clark.
Oh, no.
This is the intro.
Go on, Clark.
Do your thing.
Eventually.
Okay, okay.
He's starting.
He's good.
He's gonna do it.
Oh my god.
He's beautiful.
My words will warm and calm you.
Oh, sorry.
I thought this was my part.
Let daylight dry your tears.
I'm here with you, beside you.
To guard you and to guide you.
Say you'll love me every waking moment.
Turn my head with talk of summer time.
Say you need me with you now and always.
Promise me that all you say is true.
That's all I ask of you.
Let me be your shelter.
Let me be your light.
You're safe.
No one will find you.
Your fears are far behind you.
All I want is freedom.
A world with no more night.
And you always beside me.
To hold me and to hide me.
Say you'll share with me one love, one lifetime.
Let me lead you from your solitude.
Say you'll lead me with you here beside you.
Anywhere you go, let me go.
To Christine.
That's all I ask of you.
Say you'll share with me one love, one lifetime.
Say the word and I will follow you.
Say you'll stay with me each night, each morning.
Say you'll love me all I do.
Thanks, Clark.
Love me.
That's all I ask of you.
Wait, I don't remember that part.
Love, love me.
Okay.
I started laughing because I thought I was going to be singing with him.
Oh.
Why is he looking at me like that?
He wants me to continue?
Oh, here we go.
And you will let me go too.
Love me.
That's all I ask of you.
Wait, why are you so quiet?
Love me.
I can't ever sing this song seriously.
Oh, sorry, Clark.
You sang beautifully.
I was laughing because...
Oh my gosh, I was laughing because...
I thought I was supposed to be singing with him in the chorus, but it was just him.
I realized because it said...
Okay, it said like, now we both sing this part.
And I was like, oh no.
I just sang over him before when I wasn't supposed to.
It made me laugh.
Whoopsie.
Hopefully that was good enough for you guys.
Okay, I think I can do one more song.
One more song.
I don't know what to sing at all.
And thank you for the donuts, you guys.
When's the album coming out?
Stop it.
Can you do...
Let me practice it a couple more times.
Bad apple.
Golden hour.
I would have to put the... what's it called?
The pitch up though.
And I can't do that on YouTube.
But bad apple is a good song.
I never said it was a bad song.
I love you.
I love you more and more.
That's also a really hard song for me to sing.
I'm like...
I have no idea.
Any Toho song?
I ship Mint and Clark now.
Please don't.
Lion?
Not like...
Ba-da-da-da-dun-dun-dun-dun.
That one.
Oh, I don't know.
Oh, oh my gosh.
Oh, Diamond Crevice.
You know what?
I will sing that one because I was supposed to sing it before.
Oops.
Diamond crevasse karaoke.
There we go.
I was supposed to sing that one.
Someone asked for that one last time.
I said I would.
But...
Okay.
Break stuff.
I'm not trying to break my throat today.
Okay.
We will do it.
We will sing break stuff one day.
Don't worry.
One day.
One karaoke we'll sing break stuff.
This is Diamond Crevasse from Macross.
.
恋をしてたこれで最後に もう一度抱きしめて欲しかったよ Oh, it's long, long goodbye さよなら さよなら 何度だって 自分に無情に言い聞かせて
手を振るのは優しさだよね Oh, 今強さが欲しい
あなたに出会いした輝いて 私が生まれて
愛すればこそ 愛あればこそ 希望のない奇跡を待って どうなるの?
涙に滲む 星の瞬きはゴール Ah,
I love you!
忘れないよ あなたも その優しさも すべて包んでくれた 両手も
It's long, long goodbye さよなら さよなら 愛しい人 あなたがいたから 歩いてこれた 一人なんかじゃなかった
たった一人が欲しい パンパン!
オバカリア!
燃えるような汁 人生捕まえて 人を灯して 愛していたい 愛さえ 火を使う方もばっかり 増えたんだ世界も
虚勢が溶けて どうしてなの?
涙増えて
止められない 愛すればこそ 愛あればこそ 希望のない奇跡もあって どうなるの?
涙に滲む
星の瞬きはどうなの?
どうならば 満たせるなら 終えるなら I did the wrong part!
その後
私を見つけ出して もう二度と離さないで 捕まえてて 一人じゃないと
欲しいプラネット 見せる
食券です ありがとうございます さようなら That was the last song.
最後の曲でした ありがとうございました
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
This was your first time seeing me.
I'm Mint.
I'm a Vtuber.
And I play games and I sing sometimes.
I'm a spooky ghost.
So if you want to subscribe, that'd be pretty cool.
We have lots of fun here, don't we, guys?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, okay.
First time here.
Shut up, Miguel.
Gracias, gracias.
Muchas gracias.
Arigatou, arigatou.
When...
Oh, Rock Barabbit, thank you for the okonomiyaki.
Thank you for the karaoke.
Cheered me up a ton.
I hope you feel better, too.
I can never get enough of your amazing voice.
And I can never express how glad I am.
You're back.
Mr. Noblesse, thank you so much.
As I thought, Minto-chan.
You have a good voice.
Arigatou, uncle.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay.
Hello, hello.
Goodbye, goodbye.
Bye, bye.
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, see you.
See you when I see...
Oh, tomorrow I'll have a stream.
I'll be playing a spooky horror game.
So, yes.
Let's play.
Spooky...
Spooky game.
Bye, bye.
What's up, Minto?
Bye.